le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
créer un espace d'expression et de
dialogue pour les citoyens de demain
c'est l'objectif du conseil
départemental des jeunes depuis 1989
le cdj permet aux élèves des collèges
réunionnais de se réunir comme leurs
aînés pour mettre en place des actions
sur des thématiques qui les concerne
tous les ans des élections sont
organisées pour composer le nouveau
conseil
[Musique]
on sait recevoir
j'ai envie d'être
rente annuelle de 63 jeux
ils ont à peine 13 ans et déjà le
courage de défendre leurs opinions à
saint-andré ces élèves du collège bédié
pourrait bien devenir membre du cdj
conseil départemental des jeunes
[Musique]
ce matin la géci robert responsable du
cdj au département explique aux
collégiens le principe de cette
initiative
[Musique]
allez on vient dans les collèges parce
que c'est la période où on sélectionne
les conseillers départementaux jeunes
des différents niveaux de 4e 5e et 3e
le conseiller départemental jeunes il
est aux représentants du collège il est
là pour justement faire partie de
l'instance et mettre en place des
projets on l'apprend à devenir autonomes
à pouvoir se responsabiliser pour le
tronçon à venir je donnais les ans elle
continue
elsa est entré au lycée cette année elle
faisait partie des conseillers
départementaux l'an passé une expérience
qu'elle est venue partager avec ces cas
d un procès des années inoubliables que
vous allez passer
vous voyez avec des étoiles dans les
yeux et c'est exactement ce que je
voulais faire ressentir les ce que je
voulais partager avec eux les jeunes
aussi peuvent faire des choses et
participer à la vie active et ça nous
prépare nous aussi à notre rôle de
citoyens de demain parce que c'est nous
les citoyens de demain et c'est pour ça
que on est là aujourd'hui pour soutenir
les adultes et montrer que la jeunesse
réunionnaise elle est présente
un élève de 3e
kieran entame lui sa dernière année au
cdj et il compte bien motivés et
camarades pour qu'ils en fassent autant
désastre que nous on va mener bras qu'on
puisse les expliquer et donnait 7 7 7 me
fait envie
donc avec deux élèves de l'établissement
car aujourd'hui les élèves vont élire un
nouveau représentant au conseil
départemental des jeunes
en lice quatre candidats mais il y en a
un qui remporte presque tous les
suffrages
élu à la majorité
nathan devient donc suppléant délégué au
cdj première mission pour le collégien
et ses camarades élire leur président
[Musique]
une assemblée qui se tient dans le même
hémicycle que leurs aînés du département
nullement impressionné les jeunes
conseillers aspirants à la présidence
défendre leur programme
[Musique]
toute l'année les conseillers mettront
en place des actions autour du programme
choisi
ils seront accompagnés par leurs
collègues d'adultes très fiers de
l'implication de cette jeunesse vous
jeunes quand un potentiel énorme et je
constate puisque je suis le conseil
départemental des jeunes depuis quelques
années maintenant je vois que plus les
années passent plus nos jeunes sont
performants
plus nos jeunes sont engagés et plus nos
jeunes se peaufine dans leurs projets et
ça c'est important à bosser au terme du
premier tour
les conseillers tombent d'accord c'est
victor élève au collège montgaillard à
saint denis qui sera leur président
cette année c'est juste fantastique pour
moi c'était juste un rêve en fait et
voilà que j'ai gagné dix a le plus plu
tard j'aimerais faire la politique qui
je mettrai tout mon amour dans le
conseil départemental des jeunes le
jeune président veut mener des actions
pour la lutte contre la misogynie et
l'homophobie la gestion de l'eau à la
réunion ou encore la valorisation des
compétences des jeunes
c'est le coeur serré que les conseillers
les plus âgés c'est leur place 120
quiétude néanmoins la relève est assurée
[Musique]
le conseil départemental des jeunes
permet de donner la parole aux jeunes de
les aider à devenir des citoyens
responsables prendre part et participer
à la vie de leur collège le cdj
s'adresse aux collégiens
chaque collège à trois représentants ils
participeront à des assemblées plénières
et organiseront des commissions et des
actions en lien avec leur programme
pour plus de renseignements sur le
conseil départemental des jeunes
vous pouvez consulter le site
www.cggveritas.com
[Musique]